rory mcleod so good to have you in the
house your
journey and your story it's like one of
the most inspirational stories ever
so i want to start with where you are
now very briefly so your business now
you're turning over about eight million
pounds per year
yeah probably the main business doing
about eight million a year
and then got like some other kind of
businesses and property and
on top of that on top of that okay
you're doing some
really exciting development stuff and
especially over the last couple of years
which
which you want to get into and you
started out in a totally different
scenario you started with nothing you're
you're
working class on drugs as a teenager
your mum was taken off to a psychiatric
ward when you were when you were a kid
so really rough start so i'm really
curious as to how you got from that to
where you are now
so there's a lot to get through but i
think people are gonna be gripped
there's gonna be a lot of golden nugget
pearls of wisdom hopefully some
inspiration because people will be able
to relate to you
that might have nothing or have come
from a bad place but also people
that are wanting to really scale things
because you're a great business scaler
so
how did it start talk to me a bit about
your background your upbringing
and and how you got from that to where
you are now yeah well my dad was a
teacher
and my mom was like a housewife but
initially i suppose when my parents kind
of split up
and there wasn't a lot of money like it
wasn't a very good scene so
i was kind of forced to kind of try and
make my own money
so when i was about 12 years old
i went to work in a news agents
pakistani news agents in a wee village
called dun toker where i lived
and i got 75 pence an hour and i worked
in the evenings and then i had a large
paper round
on a sunday and yeah but the age of 12
i was probably making like kind of 30
quid
a week which was a fortune so that kind
of
uh basically that was the money i used
to live and well morty kind of fund
my extra curricular activities but i did
learn about
having to work hard to make money even
on the paper round it was quite large i
had to
can i have some basic administration
kind of keeping a log of who paid what
and
counting my money and i had to buy the
papers and i made
profit and that was my money and that
was the money for the papers next week
and
i had sort of my business sort of
brain was beginning to form at that age
and it was more out of necessity other
people get pocket money and
stuff and i suppose i kind of resented
them because it was like they get money
from their parents
that they would use to get a drink at
the weekend whereas i had to work for my
money and i was kind of like
at the time i resented it now i look
back thank god that it was a god's gift
because i really learned that very young
age like
how to make money so that was kind of
probably the start yeah
how did you get started on drugs like
how did that start as a 12 year old
right
yeah i smoked my first joint when i was
12. it was just like a local guy had
some dope
and we went a like our primary school
and we we managed to roll like a spliff
and i remember smoking it and feeling
like can i
i suppose i felt like a bit kind of
elated or like
can i out of it which for me was quite a
nice
experience because at the time it was
about rough my dad
and mom had kind of went the separate
ways my mom was having mental health
issues strongly and i kind of
experienced this
kind of feeling it was like wow it took
me away from that sort of environment so
it was quite attractive and then it was
the same i started
drinking on my first drink when i was
12. i had three bottles of cider
uh like guy called michael and we went
out and get drunk and then i just
started
doing that every every weekend and and
that's why i would sit in
my room play my computer work and go
and get drunk and take drugs whereabouts
were you living you're in scotland right
yeah it's outside of glasgow i i two
areas clay bank which is a
predominantly working class area and
then bears them which is a more kind of
upper-class area so i was
i was kind of between the two so i got
to see both kind of sides of the divide
yeah so you started your first business
and i know you were cleaning stairs
right quite early on was that your first
business yeah
yeah oh god i'm going to throw you
another one but i went to university
and i got a degree in business and it
was complete waste of time i'm sorry if
anyone's doing
university and i'd be in the art school
and different things and then
i ended up in edinburgh cleaning stairs
and that was like kind of my first sort
of grown-up business
and doing tax returns and these
different things and i
i had a real stigma about doing it
because i had a degree
and here i'm mopping stairs and cleaning
stairs
and then i quickly saw that i could
motor
multiply and i could actually make a lot
of money doing it
and i did and then i got to the point
where i was kind of making like
in a day what most people were making in
a week yeah
it's your your background's interesting
because i mean i've
spoke to a lot of people that are
multi-millionaires i'm a
multi-millionaire myself
and most people that i know that are
very wealthy now have done really well
for themselves in business as a kid had
a paper round
and people think when you oh rich people
they were born wealthy and but actually
a lot of there's a lot of people out
there that were born
born into poverty almost and and have
actually
become wealthy because they had to learn
business they had no
they had to learn business what what you
said your experience with university
wasn't good i mean the fact that you
even got into university is a bit of a
bit of a miracle yeah it was yeah yeah i
mean
yeah that was a struggle it wasn't the
finest university the main reason why i
went was to get the grants and student
loans
to to fund partying and go
in holiday and stuff like that but like
i i used to sleep through the lectures
and stuff i didn't there wasn't a lot of
information absorbed so was it was it
that the uni was bad or was it that it
was great but you just slept through it
i just i just didn't know how to study
and i'd never i've not i tried whenever
i've
picked up any books i generally just
kind of fall asleep or i just couldn't
grasp i couldn't study i didn't know how
to learn it'd be interesting as well as
the contrast because i know over the
last couple of years you've been
absorbing
a lot of my content online and learning
about property which has been helpful
with your recent developments
is interesting to the contrast between
formal education and then self-education
yeah what do you think about that well
like like like when i was looking at
your stuff for example online
what they don't do you name what you do
is you will show
a real-life real-life example
of here's a property here's the
different ways
you can buy it i'm going to explain it
to you in detail
like and you really go into it so is it
someone that doesn't
know anything about buying a property or
rent a property or
buying and selling or any of these
different like models that you teach
like
if somebody watches enough of your
content
they can then do it because the
information's all there university is a
different thing whereby
somebody's got a set sort of our
talk and you have to listen and you have
to try and piece it together with other
stuff whereas your stuff's
fluid and you're it's very well laid out
and you're given lots of examples you're
you know there's even it sounds silly
but even pictures and film
help a person understand more of a
subject
than just the written word that's why i
think
that's my personal view that's why
you've done so well because it's it's
real life
and you really go into it in detail and
you give examples so there's not
much mystery there if somebody really
watches your stuff yeah and that's what
i found i started
probably about like i said to you about
two years ago my business partner stuart
like introduced me to your stuff online
and that's when we started
like watching your videos and a lot of
this kind of stuff we were trying like
seller finance and different things i
didn't actually know if it was legal
i was like is this because you're taught
you just get a mortgage you know you get
a mortgage for your house or you get a
mortgage for a buy
a rent and and this is the thing and
then here's this guy coming along
giving you all these different ways of
doing it and what i learned from you
when i was looking at it was like
buying a house is like buying anything
else it's like
if you want to buy a boat and the guy
selling it for a hundred thousand quid
and you get 50
you can see them look can i give you 50
and then i'll give you the other 50
through time or could you
give me 50 and i'll borrow 50 and then
you know you you can
structure some sort of deal you buy that
thing and it's the same with the house
providing the
solicitors and lawyers can put something
in
you you can you can do it and when i saw
your stuff i was like wow there's
somebody else out there
like that's doing it then when i really
looked at your stuff i was like wow he's
doing
a lot of stuff like way more than us i
was like that was cool because it was
like
and then i thought god i'd really like
to meet this guy yeah and then
yeah and we've become friends since and
i've learned a lot from you as well
about business and
and personal development and things and
it's it's i'm really honored
that i've been able to play a part in
your journey on the property side i want
to talk a little bit about your
development side of the business that
you've been doing the last couple of
years because you've done some
incredible deals and i think taking your
business acumen that that you've got and
also your
your courage and that's that's what
you're just someone that just gets up
and goes
and that's i think that's one of the
reasons why you're turning over eight
million on your business is because
you're
you're a doer um a normal guy
from a very underprivileged background
that's just
developed yourself and i want to talk to
you about that as well shortly
about how you've done that um but let's
talk a little bit about some of the
properties so
talk to me about the the bomb that you
bought i want i want to know the numbers
the figures
what happens and when you bought it well
it's funny because it was like
on some of your like seminars you're
talking about like how you got the
deposit showing money in the accounts
and
you've got there's always going to be
about a wheeler and dealing in the
background and trying to
do things creativity right creativity
because most people most people when
their door shuts in their face
they go oh it's not meant to be oh it's
actually no no the door's shooting your
face
you've got to walk around it you've got
to find another door or you've got to
kick that door down yeah
and and and i think that's just what you
have to do as an entrepreneur and people
someone who's a a belt embraces jobs
worth red tape person might frown upon
that and say oh that's not good or you
shouldn't have done that all
but you're not breaking the law you're
just sometimes breaking the rules a
little bit and arnold schwarzenegger
talks about this he says don't break the
law
but sometimes you have to break the
rules and for sure and you don't get to
where
you're at without something not doing
that 100
i mean that was it was i mean the barn
in the house
a project was a cash only
offers those cash only offers uh and
it was uh i think they were advertising
at 450
500 000 or something and there was
people that approached me and you saying
listen
this place available but it's cash only
uh we don't
have the cash so do you fancy doing it
and kind of where we're like
like too many people involved and then
when a sort of developer guys goes look
if you're probably putting an offer a
half a million you'll get that now we
didn't have
cash only so we had to say oh yes we've
got cash only and we've got the money
but then we had to find the money in
what ways so we bought the place
uh well we agreed half a million it
later valued at 450 000
we couldn't get it any more valued so
then the seller actually sold is it for
450.
so hold on you agreed to buy it for 500
000 pounds yeah
but then when you had it valued and it's
good that you valued it before you
bought it
even though you're buying it cash yes
you you added value before you bought it
it came at 450. so then you knew what we
negotiated
yeah we just went back and said look
like it's 450 we can't
there was some sort of not weed or
something in the field
that was the one that was like and it
was like oh and everything was like oh
yeah that's so funny that you say that
there was some kind of not weird
to some people it'll be like holy moly
japanese 100
i mean some of my properties have had
japanese not weird what let me ask you a
question though some people might be
thinking this
because your business is doing very well
you're turning over eight million on
your gutting business which i know makes
a net profit of about twenty percent
why would you not have the cash
available is that because you've
invested it elsewhere is that just
because
like how can someone that's turning over
so much money yeah who has been in for
quite a long time
yeah not have not been very liquid oh
yeah not have much cash in there
no i i never really hold cash like i've
we've got
i mean stewart my business partner i've
got like six commercial
properties i'd bought another house at
the same time
that i was doing it and generally i will
try and borrow
money to do these sort of things i've
got money in the bank and different
things but
we will always try and borrow it like
and try not to
tie too much our liquid cash and that
sort of that's
that's a foreign concept to most people
though uh rory because
most people in their mindset would think
borrow some borrow
if you can't afford to buy it yourself
right don't but if you can afford to buy
yourself don't borrow it what would you
say to that
no it's just like i mean if you can get
the money
like the way i look at it is if you can
get like money and you can borrow money
to do a deal which stacks up that gives
you a profit
yeah and you pay back the money you've
you planned you don't essentially need
to put in anything to do the deal and
then you pull out
a lump or a profit or the thing starts
cash flowing back once it's paying off
the debt
so then that if you can get the money
like that you can do more things
if you just take your 200 grand and slam
in your property
that's you limited also a lot of the
time
when the bank and different lenders are
looking at you they want to look at well
how much money's this guy got
and then if you're sitting with bank
accounts are all overdrawn you'll get
loads of debt
nobody wants to touch you like my credit
rating just now is 999 i've got the
highest credit rating you've got
but i've got hundreds of thousands of
pounds of debt
but that's fine it's all well controlled
so it's about managing the debt then 100
and also i mean someone said to me a
very wealthy friend i have he said
if you if you've got millions of pounds
even if you're a multi multi millionaire
if you've got millions of pounds in the
bank you're probably a bad businessman
yeah you know because because if you're
a good businessman how could you sit
with millions of pounds in the bank yeah
i mean i know i know when i've got a lot
of money in the bank it
irks me yes now you want to leave a
little bit in because you never know
when you might need it or when a cushion
could happen if you've got staff you
need to be responsible for your business
but but generally speaking okay so you
buy this place for
450 000 pounds yeah what happens next
yeah well we bought it for 450 some
bridging finance different things we put
in a little bit our own money it wasn't
like totally all financed and then we
renovated
the property and that was we spent about
50
60 000 pound renovating the house with
some land
kind of garage nice big driveway and
then we rented that out
and then that that values today at 4 50
so the actual
house's value is the value of what we
bought the whole site first on top of
that we've got some land
and a large like it's a large commercial
sort of barn
and then we rent that out as well which
is incredible and depending on how you
look at this
i mean if you and how much so so the
house is worth 450
yeah and you bought the whole site for
four figures
you invested 50 to 60 000 pounds around
the boat yet so if the house on its own
is worth
450 that basically means you've got a
free barn
pretty much yeah and then somebody had
offered 250 on the barn
to buy office with the land around that
we rejected that so
i mean a property is worth whatever well
anyone's willing to pay for it and
that's
and we wouldn't sell it for 250 so yeah
250 profit
just now as it stands which is great
yeah and that's also rented out so
that's given us an income as well that
burn
and what's the plan are you going to are
you going to refinance the barn
yeah i don't know i need to speak to you
about that later on
i probably would but okay that's that's
absolutely incredible what were some of
the challenges with that you said you
mentioned those japanese not weird who
how did you get and this is another
thing about about you and
this is where your business acumen comes
into it
your background in business which is
just fantastic is that you're good at
getting good people around you
and i've seen you've got an instagram
channel and i sometimes just look
through a scroll of the videos and i see
you've got a great setup you've got a
really clean office
great staff they all seem happy how do
you manage to to build a power team
i mean how do you get good people around
you
with property with business to manage
these processes yeah well i mean
a number one is my business partner
stuart
i met him god probably 15 20 years ago
we first met
he i mean him struck off a lot of the
people around me i'm always looking at
like
how how is the person in life like how
are they
with themselves you know how what's the
state of their belongings you know do
they have a lot of friends
like are they honest you know are they
ethical
are they hard working you know what sort
of things do they update and i'm always
looking out for
good people all the time and if i see
anyone i think wow that like they took
all the boxes that i have formed over
time i'll try and employ the people
and then there's sometimes people that
don't tick the boxes or you've maybe
employed them and then
stuff comes to light and then it's like
they actually detract from the
organization or they detract from
you so you have to kind of get them out
because you want to have a team around
you like what you've got
of people that are hardworking ethical
honest they've got your back you don't
have to worry about them you know
they can have access to your bank
accounts they can allow access to your
house
like you don't lose any sleep around
them and when you've got that it gives
you stability so
that that's that's my kind of ethos that
i really like to build these people
around me
you definitely can't do it on your own
it's too it's
it's trying to go out on your own and
create this sort of stuff out of teams i
would say is pretty much impossible
i agree and you know what you don't need
to know
everything about everything you just
need good people around you i really
strongly believe that everything that
has gone wrong in my property business
the mistakes the problems
has always been around people the
builders have messed up the tenants
aren't paying their rent they're letting
edges but then
who chose that builder what was me yeah
and who employed that letting agent and
who found that
and ultimately all comes back to me the
entrepreneur
so the the skill of being able to find
and select
good people and that's something that
you are amazing
at knowing who to work with who to find
i think he's is a really really
important skill you've got any tips top
tips for finding good people and knowing
who you can trust
yeah i think i mean there's a lot of
tips but i would look at like
it's really simple it's like i i think
having an employee or a business partner
is kind of like having
a wife or a partner it's like is this
person going to be faithful to me
you know is this person when they talk
about me you know how's this person
act so when i'm talking to someone i'm
aware are they talking about other
people
like in a negative fashion yes oh this
person's talking a lot
negatively about others so why am i
going to be any different
you know or is the person faithful to
their partner
no they're not faithful they're
partnered they're not going to be
faithful to me
you know is the person taking drugs does
the person
trust themselves you know do they if
they don't trust them oh no i don't i
don't want to get into this
situation because i don't trust myself
okay well they don't trust themselves
they're going to trust
me you see and sometimes i'm not like
i'm not a master i'm i
i okay i'm probably worth a three four
million quid or something like that i'm
not
testing that's conservative if you value
your business yeah it may be okay if i
but the point is like i still make
mistakes but i'm always learning i'm
like oh god i didn't spot that i didn't
see that but it's like
you really want to look at like what's
the person's actions
because whenever i interview people if
you just listen to what the person says
the p
it's very easy to talk like a good talk
it's very easy to say
all the correct things but you really
want to look at the person's track
record you want to speak to people that
know that person you want to get
referrals you really want to drill down
and i actually use a really good
recruitment company who the owner of the
recruitment company i know
personally and they're really good at
that so now as i'm moving
sort of larger businesses and
organizations but i need
more senior managers i use them because
they really
drown down on that with regards to the
person's actions in the past because i
don't have time
to do that just now but they use the
same formula
that i use so that's why i use them and
that's incredible and
talk to me as well because i know you've
done in the last couple years you've
done other stuff
yeah um and your your business partner
steve no sorry
sure um who who recommended you to start
watching my courses and
my my content didn't he come across me
wasn't it a negative video that he came
across to begin with
i thought like so someone exposed video
or something
no i think like i mean
one of the things i've noticed and sure
knows it as well was like if you're
out in the public eye and you're doing
well and you're successful
you're gonna get attacks like if yeah
in fact if you're not getting attacked
you're probably not been out there
enough
and yeah stewart was watching like there
was
i think god okay he was watching some of
your videos which he really liked
and then there was some other stuff that
was like negative or whatever
yeah yeah but in fact there was i think
he must have been your friend there was
a guy who was
bald and he was from scotland and he had
a similar business to you
you know buddies or neighbors or was the
guy called
so you start watching these uh stuart
start seeing these like expose videos
he's been watching them he's been
following you for two years he actually
getting you before the expose videos
okay but the explosive videos um
what me and stuart know about life when
you find well what was going on here
yeah it's like
samuel's doing really big getting really
successful
here comes the attacks yeah you know and
then if you get
through that because you'll have it from
employees internally you'll sometimes
get that these sort of attacks we'd
one guy was stealing from us for two
years but you'll get external as well
and then it's like well how
a lot of people could just crumple and
fold and one thing stewart was like
full of admiration for was the way you
fought back
and then really pinpointed all these
facts
this guy said and then replaced it with
the truth
was like here's this lie here's the
truth here's a lie here's the truth
here's a lie here's the truth and by the
way i've been looking at you
truth truth truth the guy just
and it's like that yeah and i don't want
to be hard on
on the people that do these types of
videos you should
but everybody has their own agenda yeah
and everyone's coming from from their
own place
and sometimes from my perspective being
selfish
having people doing doing like looking
at you in the spotlight and trying to
catch you out and stuff and god bless
them
i have no hard feelings for them it
actually makes me better because
because i'm i'm now so i've now suddenly
got people in my blind spots
and if i if i if i'm going off course
yes i've got people i'm accountable to
and i've got friends
but actually if you've got you know
haters or whatever you want whatever you
want to say
it's not necessarily a bad thing so
no and it was a tough it was a tough
season and and
and you know while it lasts and i feel
now it's you know we're kind of over
that now but but who knows what can
happen in the future
but it's just great to have people like
yourself who
have come on you've done some of the
online stuff you've learned
you've seen that but then you've
actually you've got
your your business savvy eye and you're
able to just see actually you know
these are the facts this is what's out
there um you know so
thank you for your support for your
support in that no my pleasure um
talk to me about the other development
the little place that you bought well i
just i mean
like the main things like the business
but i love property my dad's
bought and sold about six or seven
houses by the time i was about nine
years old we moved a lot and i saw how
he made money just from buying a
property
under the market value doing up and
selling over the market value and that
was his sort of
method and he did that quite steadily
throughout my childhood we'd move every
couple of years and then i was just
driving past
and i saw this bungalow and quite a big
plot
and i looked up online 350 thousand two
bed bungalow
i thought god that's there's a that is a
big plot for 350 especially down where i
am
um in west sussex and we went and the
guy was like 350
375 and i said well look he was very
negative about it but when i noticed
there was like two bedrooms and three
reception rooms and a huge big back
garden i thought this could be a four
bed
and i i said okay look 3 50 and the late
it was in probate or something
uh the lady passed away and the family
accepted the 350
and that was my primary residence
because i
i always rent i've always rented
properties over the last 10 years
and i put about a hundred thousand in
here we've extended it out the back
you know new bathroom suite plumbing
electrics blah blah blah spent about a
hundred thousand on it
like nice driveway landscaped all the
gardens
big patio doors you name it and then it
got valued there just at 5.50 so when
i'm 200 000
i spent 100 and then i made a hundred
thousand
yeah and then because it's my primary
residence yeah boy
i don't barely tax so that's all so that
that's no cavity
just get that if anyone's watching
you're living it yourself any profit
that you make on it if you
the zero capital gains tax yes which is
incredible yeah so it's good so yeah
i've run those two projects in time
it was interesting as well is that most
people especially when they're living in
it and you lived in it for business
reasons of course because you're
commercially savvy
but most people they'll be like oh i
want a conservatory and they'll spend
30 grand putting a conservatory in but
they'll push the value up of the house
by 30 grand so it's completely pointless
yeah or sometimes in some cases they'll
spend 50 grand
on a fancy conservatory and slabs
and the house we only got invaded by 25
grand yeah so it doesn't make sense but
what what you've done is you've spent
100 grand which sounds like a lot but
you've pushed the value up by 200 grand
you made a hundred thousand pounds tax
free profit interesting that you said
that you
usually rent where you live yeah because
you know i teach that
yeah yeah yeah um so that's again people
people
watching this might think how is this
guy this guy says he's making great
money he's
the business is doing really well he's
been in business fears but he rents
where he lives
he doesn't have millions in the bank
it's but but but what people don't
understand is that's not
how to do it so why do you normally
until you're doing this for tax reasons
why do you normally rent where you live
what's the
what's the rationale behind that i i
just i mean
how our business is has really doubled
every year in size so that that takes
money so the money we make
we'll put back in we'll do other
property deals and stuff that but
fundamentally
the main kind of upset i have with
owning your own houses
you have to have a large chunk of cash
sitting in it yeah and when i say sana
it's not true the large chunk of cash
goes to the bank
and the bank uses that money to make
more money
so they take your money and they go and
invest it and what frustrates me is is
my money
so i'm better to take that money and
invest it and use it for things than the
bank and that's really
all it was and again when i saw you
really
pushing the fact that people should rent
the house it validated
what i've been doing and i was like good
there's another successful guy doing
what i'm doing i'm on the right track
a lot of that has been validation you
know over the last couple years like
you're looking at doing stuff and
a lot of it has been validation because
you you've messaged me and you've said
oh good i'm on the right track or
i was thinking about doing bridging on
this but that makes sense because that's
what you're talking about
and i think that's really powerful and
it just it just shows the
the importance of what i'm doing because
i'm putting out content i'm doing stuff
online
and it you know it really it makes me
feel so fulfilled knowing that
people are actually benefiting from it
on a financial level
and more than a financial level you
spend so
much time giving back helping people
having taking people out for dinners um
i saw a quote once and it said if you
want to be great don't just stand with
great people but also sit with broken
people
and that's something that i know you do
you've got a a very strong faith
um talk to me a little bit about that
because i know it's been
really really influential in your life
and it's been a real
pivot from getting you from a drug
addict with with a really rough
upbringing to happily married now for
how many years got
10 i think yeah but growing up you
couldn't be with what you couldn't
no no i mean yeah i mean i thought what
you're talking about is basically i got
any scientology when i was
and by the way just right there because
i'm going straight where people are
going
you know like if i mean when when i
first was introduced
um to to not just you but but to
grant cardone who introduced me to
charlie i'm like oh my goodness this
cult you know do i want to have a dinner
with rory or is he going to try and
convert me and are they going to be
going to be drinking babies blood you
know you hear these crazy things and i
feel like in the same way that i have
been
bashed by the media i feel that
scientology has taken a real bashing
and i mean you know from what i have
i've seen and experienced i mean i've
learned so much from you
and from charlie and from grant um you
know
incredible people with incredible
principles so i just wanted to put that
out there because
people might be thinking i was really
liking rory until until he mentioned
he's a scientologist and now
um but but but you really are a great a
great person and i think you need to
just take people
for what they are so yeah anyway there's
my disclaimer not that i needed to put a
disclaimer out there but
go on no no i mean was funny because
when i saw you were a christian
and and it was something that you
promoted in yourself i thought well i
like this guy a lot because he
he's he's been who he is and he's
promoting who he is and i think that's
important people
do that i mean i don't really get any
much of the stuff in the media and stuff
because
i've got loads of friends i have loads
of employees and i know loads of people
that know me they know what i do and
scientology has helped me a massive deal
like you said i was
like taking a lot of drugs when i was a
kid and and i was pretty much
inhabited my main problem was that i
couldn't be in a relationship or even
get in a relationship with
a woman and i along to be with someone
and that was one of my big problems
and i couldn't i wasn't achieving my
dreams i mean i was working on a call
center after i'd finished university
uh on twelve thousand quid a year and
like driving through
eddingston like two hours like an hour
there an hour back every day
selling car insurance on the phone and i
was just broken i was just
a bit lost and can i didn't really know
where i was going didn't really have a
purpose and er
scientology really i mean i did like a
detox thing and it kind of
cleaned me up a bit physically which was
kind of a good relief and then
they do like kind of they've got lots of
tools to help you with like
communication and even like
business like some of the the sort of
basic business courses that i did that
grant cardone's done and stuff like that
like one of those courses was more than
what i'd learned in my four years at
university doing business
yeah and the way it's structured and the
way it's designed it's really easy you
understand because
as soon as they mentioned like books and
courses i was kind of like i'm out i
can't read i can't study
that no no it's just done in a really
nice gradient a lot of videos and
practical examples and it was that's
where i started like my little stair
cleaning business had like
um seven or eight stair contracts and i
quickly took it to 50 using these
principles
in scientology and then i met my wife
in scientology in edinburgh like 10 11
years ago
12 years ago maybe and then she was the
same
and it was like finally i had somebody i
could be myself i could communicate
she was like she was on my wavelength
and i was like wow like found nice
people
with really good tools and it and it for
me all scientology is and
all it's ever been is like really
effective tools that you use in life
to make your situation better and
obviously it's helped me a lot so then
i like to help others because that
that's how it does you pass it along
and and that's my passion and and i
don't make any secret of that or i don't
back down from it
same as grant and all these other people
have used it in all different aspects of
life so
that that and that's when i met stewart
my business partner and that was a
benefit as well because
i know that he's ethical i know that
he's decent i know that he's honest and
and and he has the same principles as me
so we really work well as a team
well hey i can't see how anyone could
argue with it if it's got you off drugs
if it's helped you be a better person
you know i can't really see that anymore
anyone could argue with that
um what would be your biggest piece of
advice if someone's watching this and
they're just
and maybe that that there's something in
them that's holding them back
or they want to be a successful business
person property investor
like what would be the best piece of
advice that you could give to that
person
i mean there was a there's a guy called
napoleon hell
and they said what the mind can conceive
it can achieve
there was a quote like that and i
thought like it's really important if
people have
goals or targets or dreams if they have
them
that that's the most important thing and
if you have a goal or a target and a
dream and you can actually keep thinking
about it
and working towards it you'll find
tools and ways to achieve that and i
would say like i i would say
that would probably be one of the best
things that like
that i learned that it's like i wanted a
wife i wanted a family i wanted a big
business i wanted to help people i
wanted to be happy these were all the
things that i really wanted i wasn't
but i wanted them and i was willing to
look and search
for tools or ways to achieve that yeah
and i think it's really important for
people to
even write down or have their goals have
their targets like
like really don't be shy to
to dream and put that down on paper or
even
if you're brave enough tell another
person that you trust like this is what
i'd really like to achieve
and the more you talk about it the more
you look at it the better your chances
are of getting it
yeah and you're guttering business
because it's one of the biggest in the
uk right
yeah the biggest yeah oh sorry is it the
biggest what's it what's it called ben's
gutters
ben's such a simple name
simple name simple business but
absolutely killing it
um what are the plans for the future
then what do you want to do on the
property side on the business side
what's next well again that's
that's stewart's and like our business
we share that together
and we've got we're we're doing more
property
we're going we've actually taken it
believe it or not to belgium we've taken
it to switzerland
these businesses and it's worked there
so we're trying the model in different
places
stewart's got other business ventures
i've got other business ventures
but really i mean we've got like plans
together and planned separate but it's
for expansion it's for growth it's for
helping people it's getting the word out
like teaming up with people we know
meeting new people that building growing
and and having fun and having a laugh
and having more kids and
you know nice cars and and doing all
those things about you you always seem i
i follow you on instagram now you always
seem to be having a good time when
you're going about business
uh which i think is really important
it's also really important as well
sometimes to say no to deals i know you
were looking at
um you actually sent it across to me
you're looking at buying 48 houses
it was this big thing and you were
really close to completing on it but
then
in the end we just it was like actually
it's not a great deal there's a lot of
bad tenants the figures
don't quite work and it didn't tick the
boxes and you walked away from that
yeah so i think it's important to grab
life by the horns but also sometimes you
do need to say no to things
yeah yeah um talk to me a little bit
about that and why you chose not to go
there
yeah well i mean it was actually i mean
one another way you can buy
a large amount of properties is if you
buy a company you'll know that yourself
of course and that that has its
i for me it has a lot more pros than it
has cons
but again it was just like it was
actually i think it was 43
properties we actually did start to buy
them
and we bought started to buy shares in
the the proper com property company that
owned them
uh stewart myself and yeah it was just
after a while i was started looking at
the kind of quality of the houses the
tenants how much attention it was taking
up
and how much work it was needing done
for
what return it was profitable there was
a return
but sometimes yeah i felt like you have
to look at like what are you spending
your time on and what are you getting
back
and sometimes i think people can
get into something that's not
necessarily
really working that well but gave a lot
of time and energy and still it
there's not can i any fruit at the end
of the day so it was
i just had to look at it and i some of
the sort of
tenant situations and you know people
smashing windows and people stealing
pipe work or whatever and i just thought
you know what like the more higher-end
property the bigger stuff
seems to be a better quality a smoother
transaction
and a different sort of people i mean
for sure i mean i think that buying 43
little houses
you'd be better off probably i said this
i said this to the time you're better
off probably doing what you have done
which is going and buying a barn and
pushing the value up or buying one
bigger property
um but that make that makes sense and
it's just great to see you
see you doing so well talk to me about
the importance in your opinion your
experience
of education because you're someone that
went to university to study business
you're someone that's done my online
training you're someone who studies and
does personal development courses and
why is that such an important part to
you and do you think that would you
advise
everybody do that or talk to me about
that well i mean
education for me is is the like
absorbing a knowledge with the
idea or purpose of using that knowledge
right so a lot of people that have
a viewed and myself are at university
getting a degree or studying and they
don't actually know
where they're going or what they're
doing so in my viewpoint that's a waste
of time and it was a waste of my time i
wasted six years in higher education
because i didn't know what i was doing
and i think you have to have a purpose
it's like when i learn
when i start looking at your stuff i
really absorb it
because there's a purpose like why am i
going to use it
when i read the books like rich dad poor
dad you know pour your heart into
elon musk's latest autobiography you
know everyone hubbard's books like
this was starting to read the nike book
their day but i'm reading
these books with the idea that like what
are these guys doing
how what what moves they make and how
they're doing it and i'm
and i'm thinking we're using it so i
would say education would be
somebody learning stuff with the idea of
using it so
like people getting degrees and stuff
but what's the point what's the purpose
now if somebody's going to be a doctor
or maybe an engineer
that's got a purpose that's got an end
goal so then yeah sure you're going to
need to do education but a lot of
education i think
to be honest is is pretty much useless
especially at school as well
yeah and and people spend the crazy
thing is people say oh samuel leads oh
he sells you expensive courses he's like
hold on a minute
the most you can spend with me on any
course is ten thousand pounds now you
might think that's a lot
but that's a lot of training all these
different courses and materials
you go to university you'll spend that a
semester yeah yeah
and you'll to study sometimes philosophy
yeah
and then end up at mcdonald's surely
that's the scam
short university in college and like the
idea of working 40 hours a week for 40
years to retire on 40
of what you couldn't afford to live on
in the first place and save up money and
work hard and put it in the bank for
them to get rich
and the bank will give you money for a
wedding but not for investment that's
the scam folks
i mean as a business person what do you
think yeah a
100 agreement but people are so
brainwashed yeah they're in the system
like and people say scientology is a
call that's the cult
this is people are so brainwashed well i
think i mean i get called a couple
people saying
but i think i don't think i don't think
that's the majority of society
i think the majority of people that look
at your stuff like
it i think the majority of people that
look at scientology either thing
i don't know much about it or no that
seems fair enough
you get a small like minority of society
that are going to just put out all this
nonsense
and yeah a lot of the time going to
university
for a degree you can't use getting a
huge amount of debt and then working up
your job
and then you're stuck it's not a good
model it definitely isn't
so i think like you said the importance
of education
education is about gaining knowledge for
use
so if somebody just holds that as that's
their real right
what why am i learning this and if they
don't know why they're learning it
they should just go and get a job like
just go and get started
and if they even want to be like
something in a large field like they
want to be
some kind of guy who owns a big company
and construction just go and start
working in construction
and build your way up and spend six
years working
in construction as your education and
then you'll be fine but don't go to
unity learner
yeah i i agree and it's it's just so
funny to see
the system the way that people are
programmed to
think and to act and to behave i mean
the whole idea of debt the whole idea
that
we're encouraged to get bad debt yeah
bad debt but then
people then when i'm taking on good debt
yeah and talking openly about it
people accuse me of encouraging people
people to get them saying
this is good debt but then the media
and the government and the education
system and banks
are actively and the tv and the media
are actively encouraging people
yeah to take on bad debt yeah for things
like a house to live in themselves which
is a liability
for holidays for weddings for sofas
take it on now and pay for it later i'm
teaching take on a house now and pay for
it later on a lease option agreement not
take on a sofa and pay for it later
and by the time you go to pay for it the
sofa's trashed and it's gone down in
value and you still haven't got the
money like come on
you people are financially [ __ ] yeah
yeah well i i don't i don't even know if
okay when you say that it's like but
there's just no education
out there on finances but that's why i
like the stuff that you see in
particular what grant says grant cardone
speaks a lot
about the education of what money is
how finances are how you operate and
there's good information out there on
finances
it's i think people just don't have the
tools and and it's promoted heavily
like get yourself in the housing market
you know get yourself in the housing
ladder like
that's pushed really yes and if people
don't
aren't on the housing ladder they feel
like they're missing out or they're
losing in life but that's
that's how it's promoted they know the
housing ladder is very different to what
we're talking about
100 we're talking about become a
property business entrepreneur
and buy assets being on the housing
ladder
is about getting yourself stuck in the
rat race of
a mortgage but no rent because you're
living there yourself
yeah that's dead interest payments on
the house you live in that's dead money
not rent yeah 100 dude i could talk to
you all day
i hope people have found this interview
interesting i'd love to know the
comments
so folks please do a massive favor and
subscribe to the channel turn the
notification bell on
smash the like button if you want to get
in touch with rory i'm sure you can do
that what's the best way people get in
touch with
probably instagram say rudy mack is
r-u-r-y-m-a-c
cool so i'm i'm gonna leave in the
description i wanna leave a link for his
instagram
spam him spam him like crazy if he
disagree with anything he said just go
on and tell him and troll him that would
be fantastic
just don't troll me no do it's good for
the engagement if you liked it smash the
like button if you didn't like it smash
the dislike button because it makes no
difference to the youtube algorithm
and i look forward to seeing you on the
next video if you want to see more
winners on our wednesday videos you can
see them right here
how cool was that right there if you
want to subscribe to the channel no
you need to subscribe to the channel you
can do that right here and i look
forward to seeing you
next time